a group of senior citizens loaded up a
bus to vote early they were told to get
off that bus do you believe that voter
suppression is underway
absolutely look I have the exact numbers
but somewhere in the order of 77 in the
last couple of years a piece of
legislation introduces state legislators
to restrict the right to vote to reduce
the we should have automatic
registration we should have it allowing
everybody to vote and you know all the
stuff about all they can't let felons
you can't let it you know people who are
in this country illegally vote they have
to have an ID by the way well no they
don't have to have an ID everywhere they
have to demonstrate that they live there
and who they are they don't have to have
a particular ID they don't have to have
a government-issued ID they don't have
to have that's not true and the truth of
the matter is that all the talk about
voter fraud did the president find any
of it and this big whole thing the
reason he won the popular vote come on
come on and then but my generic point is
there is no no evidence in all of the
studies done of widespread voter fraud
of that being a central problem in
American electoral process just not true
I mean in Georgia it's reported more
than 53,000 voter registration
applications are on hold that's right
and 70% of those are African Americans
surprise surprise so do you believe
there's an effort underway
absolutely positively without question
it continues it's one of the reasons why
this museum the people in this museum
that are here now I'm being honored and
start at their fight it's still going on
it still exists and it's wrong and look
that voter ID thing if my name is Joseph
R Biden Jr if I show up and I don't have
a license that says Joseph R Biden or
doesn't have jr. on it then I can't vote
when everybody knows who the heck I am
and my voting and
and the Challenger knows who I am come
on this is designed to suppress the vote
not allow the vote